romain bouteille le café de la gare
c'est vous c'est uniquement vous
justement donc entre c'est moi je suis
chargée des publics relation guybet
s'occupe de la glace pour les boissons
enfin c'est tout c'est une bande des
normes et s'était construit à la main si
je veux dire c'est rentable c'est c'est
pas faut pas compter dessus pour faire
fortune
surtout à huit patrons mais c'est viable
l'autre
[Musique]
et comment êtes vous arrivé à faire ce
spectacle comment ça s'est fait comme
dit un beau jour on met tous ensemble ça
c'est trouver quoi sur le chantier il ya
plein de blagues c'est un endroit
propice aux blagues chantier et puis
alors bon intel a une idée pas fluide la
mer puis un autre là m petit à petit
bout à bout ça fait comme le théâtre ça
fait un spectacle ça vous improvisez
toujours tous les soirs un petit peu à
dans le spectacle même dire pratiquement
pas d'improvisation
c'est ce qu'on essaye s'étonner l'air
que ce soit improvisé m'enfin c'est
truqué ça est-ce que vous avez des
messages privés salle et non aller seul
on aime bien ça veut il a tué sa femme
elles sont charles ix saint homme
dix huit de tout sentiment humain ou un
animal ou un résumé de tout sentiment
humain ou animal végétal un loup garou
urinent sur quatre pattes
à
crois oui oui sur deux lui
et bien c'est un homme un hangar où
maintenant accorder jeu train
département cet homme est il une victime
jeté à son allure sur le fleuve de la
vicissitude isolé vers le hachoir notre
moral néo judéo chrétienne ou la
bouteille
bon je payer les dettes
le bien revoir comment ça vient comment
la suite bien il ya un projet qui est un
autre spectacle le 20 à peu près qui
s'appelle robin dé quoi alors là on est
un peu inquiet il faut que il démarre
[Musique]